What other kinds of foods would be beneficial from an epigenetic point of view?
Beneficial for cancer patients? Yes.
Well, more so what foods are probably best to stay away from a genetic point of view.
And certainly with any cancer, you're trying to limit growth. So then you look at what foods
stimulate growth pathways, metabolic pathways, and the first one that you should probably consider
dairy products. So dairy, I wouldn't say dairy is necessarily a cause of cancer, per se, but it
certainly is a stimulant to growth factors. You try to explain it to people, what is dairy for
its milk for a baby for a 60 pound cow to grow up to be a 1200 pound cow? We certainly don't want to
be adding growth factors. And I show it in videos, different men of the metabolic pathways to
get them to understand that stimulates the caross pathway, which is a growth pathway.
To get them to understand the technical side of that, but staying away from things that will stimulate
growth of the cancer. So then we talk about from a dietary standpoint, cancer needs a fuel source.
So whereas dairy is not necessarily a fuel source, it's a growth stimulator. But what is a
fuel source of a cancer? It could be fed mainly directly through the pathway called glycolysis,
which is how we break down glucose. So sugar should probably be something that all cancer patients
should refrain from. But there are certain people that their cancer is stimulated completely
off glycolysis, or that's the main source of fuel we could say. And then there's other people that
their cancer currently is fueled off of amino acid, gobbling up amino acids, and that is the
fuel source, lysine and methionate and glutamine. So those people should limit animal products
like meat. That should be the main thing that they limit, that they should be eating a bunch of
carbohydrates, but they really have to limit protein sources. And typically it's animal protein sources
what we found. So it can vary. Some people really should be eating some animal proteins, and some
people should not be eating any animal proteins. Probably every cancer across the board should stay
away from dairy. Every cancer across the board should stay away from glucose, sugar, sucrose,
has really no nutritional value. But some people don't need to stay away from fruit,
and vegetable juicy, which could be high in glucose breakdown, but has all these other
nutritional values. And if their cancer isn't fed directly through glycolysis, that's where
juicy can be very beneficial for those people. So it does vary from person to person, not so much
cancer to cancer, but person to person, the fuel source of that cancer.
Can you determine this through the DNA testing? You could get hints through the DNA testing, yes.
Dr. Godzilla and Dr. William Kelly did question-air testing, metabolic testing they called it.
We do kinesiology testing as well to help determine that. A person not having any access to any of
those things could look at how they feel after they eat those things. Or if I juice it,
I don't feel as well when I'm juicing. Or if I don't eat some meat, I don't feel well at all.
Those are some hints that you could gather for what is possibly causing your cancer growth.
Certainly, if you have a tumor that's visible and palpable, you can tell sometimes when
what you're eating is adverse to the cancer. So there's different ways that you can tell
what's what's currently feeding your cancer. But you want to try to cut off that pathway as much as possible.